les uns à la gare les autres au château
à rambouillet ce samedi de manifestation
les pro et anti chasse à courre c'est
une pratique cruelle qui consiste à
traquer un animal pendant de longues
heures pour le liquider ensuite à l'armé
blanche ou le faire noyer par les chiens
dans un étang et pour finalement donner
l'animal à manger aux chiens ce n'est
pas une chasse pour se nourrir près de
300 manifestants répondu présent à
l'appel de l'association abolissons la
vénerie aujourd'hui ils ont défilé au
son des tambours et slogan je trouve que
c'est vraiment débile on n'a pas besoin
de tenir à niveau c'est pas dégeu il
faut que ça s'arrête pour dénoncer la
barbarie de la chasse à courre et pour
dénoncer à quel point ça n'a plus lieu
d'être
au 21ème siècle la chasse leur tante
elle me dégoûte
parce que il ya de moins en moins
d'animaux en forêt parce que le
non-respect de la vie aux tambours ont
répondu les corps les pro chasse étaient
près de 400 pour défendre mon le milieu
rural on se perçoit qu'en fin de compte
il ya des gens qui sont pas de la
ruralité qui veulent décider pour des
autres et je trouve ça un peu dommage
ça fait toujours pratiqué la chasse à
courre avant chatel ou alors voyez la
forêt de rambouillet le lieu de chasse
de l'équipage de bonnel rambouillet
depuis 1871
il faut savoir qu'un équipage de chasse
à courre c'est d'abord un élevage de
chiens et si on nous supprime on met nos
chiens qui sont le fruit de siècle de
travail disparaîtront avec nous c'est
une façon de maintenir le sauvage dans
les massifs forestiers
c'est à dire essentiellement éviter que
une belle forêt comme rambouillet
soetens tentant pas fiani mallié et
finalement on dénature les animaux les
deux cortèges ont défilé sans se croiser
la chasse à courre a pris fin ce
week-end elle est autorisée chaque année
de septembre à mars selon un sondage
ifop de 2017 pour la fondation brigitte
bardot
84% des français sont opposés à la
chasse à courre